hey everybody Sean McGinnis here at e3
2014 and I'm standing next to a new face
it's our summer intern Alex new house
Alex you're not just getting us coffee
we're also sending you too honest to
goodness III appointments and you just
got a chance to check out lords of the
fallen yes that's right Sean I just saw
those the phone which is an action
action RPG being co-developed by CI
games and dec13 interactive and it looks
a lot like dark dark souls yeah that's
definitely the impression that I got
when I was hosting the demo on the live
show earlier and certainly the
impression that a lot of the chat room
had judging by their comments it's those
kind of like very intimate close
quarters environments very dimly lit and
gloomy and you're often taking on a
single enemy at a time with very slow
pace deliberate attacks so on the
surface it's got that Dark Souls vibe so
I mean that's already a really good game
what are they trying to do differently
the developers make no qualms about
saying that it is meant to be more
accessible than dark souls dark souls
really requires you to go beyond the
game and to look on gamefaqs to really
get into the game and understand what
the game's trying to do lures the pawn
takes all of that away it's perfectly
simple to just pick it up for about 20
minutes and play through it but it is
still very challenging still very
challenging yes okay so obviously they
want to maintain that aspect of it so
it's not just an action game though it's
not combats also an RPG did you get a
sense of what sort of progression
systems there are so there are a few
progression systems at the beginning you
choose a character and you can choose
one of them you can choose a set of
three different spells and these spells
are such things like fire fire bombs or
fire grenades there's also several
character bills that you can do three
classes you can choose from I didn't get
details of those but there is going to
be a pretty robust character development
system okay so if you could wrap it up
with a neat little bow what did you
think about it you like it just poor Ned
was the deal I was actually pleasantly
surprised by it it's seen a very good
and that the combat seemed pretty tight
and very interesting and they're trying
to do some interesting things with the
story which I really want to see more
about cool sounds good Alex thanks a lot
for your time Thank You Sean alright
guys that was lords of the fallen here
at e3 2014 stay tuned for more coverage